This is a little bit of a judgement call to say exactly which ones you
think are low information.
because it kind of depends on what you're looking for.
But here are a few that are classically just not
going to have that much information.
The word the. The word the shows up in almost every message that you're ever
going to see.
So the fact that the word the shows up doesn't really tell you what
the message is about, because it's always going to be there.
I would say the same thing is probably true of the word will.
And in this context also,
where we're looking at emails, I bet the word hi occurs a lot.
And so seeing the word hi doesn't necessarily tell you anything very
specific about what the message is about.
You could've also said that Katie and Sebastian are low information words,
because every message has these two words in them.
All the messages are about Katie and/or Sebastian, so
knowing that those words are there isn't necessarily telling you anything.
But I would argue that usually names are something that you would want to
be able to keep.